[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 seguramente muchos de ustedes hayan
visto decenas de películas de espías
pero qué tiene que ver el espía que
vemos en la gran pantalla con los de
verdad cómo ha evolucionado el trabajo
de espía en la era de la tecnología
donde hasta tu propio teléfono puede
espiar te hablamos de todo ello con un
ex espía ruso de la calle de ser gay
here knows ser gay muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros y muchas gracias
por haber aceptado esta entrevista en
español un idioma que conoce que estudió
en el café pero que hace tiempo que hay
mucho que no practica mucho siempre un
poco oxidado bueno usted forma parte de
la élite de los servicios secretos
soviéticos el café primero se infiltró
en la embajada de francia y después fue
enviado a parís donde integró elena a la
escuela nacional de administración
francesa como estudiante con el objetivo
de obtener información sobre la futura
elite política del
su carrera terminará con la caída de la
unión soviética tiene que exiliarse en
francia el país donde espía donde
espiaba en 2001 y después de ser acusado
de haber divulgado secretos de estado
que divulgó exactamente exactamente
ninguno es una mentira del servicio de
espionaje exterior de rusia que ya
que me acusó de haber divulgado en los
secretos del estado
hay un capítulo sobre los falsos mitos
ser espía en la vida real no es saltar
de un tejado a otro de un edificio a
otro con una pistola en la mano la
mayoría de las veces es como usted dice
en el libro conseguir informaciones y
redactar una ficha no es menos romántico
en la realidad ser espía que en las
películas de james bond no hay casi
ningún romanticismo
disponer real
por ejemplo cuando fue en el instituto
andrópov no habíamos ninguna a ninguna
ordenado ahora hacemos todos todos los
estaban los amos a mano oa máquina a
máquina mecánica y 11 otro mito no hay
chicas en el café ninguna chica
o sea que no es como en las películas
hay mucho del periodismo el trabajo del
espía quién de las películas de james
qué tipo de informaciones descubre
cuando está espiando en francia en
francia fue en la escuela que sería mega
en la arena como le presente es una
escuela muy importante porque formaba a
la alta élite francesa hay cuatro
presidentes que ya que son antiguos
alumnos de esa escuela y macrón holanda
de buck cabeza pues para el caribe para
un servicio de espionaje a esa escuela y
se le da muy importante porque forma a
futuros ministros a futuros políticos a
futuros nuevos futuros primer ministro
de presidentes y yo era el primer
soviético admitido en esta en esa
escuela
a la información que buscaba
era la información sobre la gente que
estudiaba en este en esta escuela las
calidades
cuál es su recuerdo más memorable o el
más banal de esos años de espionaje el
más memorable y es una cosa bastante
banal
porque yo envié una nota informativa al
director del café esa nota
en él
en el escritorio del presidente
gorbachov y donde se nota
recibí se nota después vi a la firmada
del jefe del gabinete de enero
y eso fue la emoción la más fuerte en mi
carrera de espía y de que era era la
nota de boldin bolden que quiera
el genio de úbeda de gabinete la firma
de de boldin se inicia que significaba
que gorbachov sí pero a la que había
escrito en esa mano
informaciones informaciones recibidas
gracias aunque tiene algún remordimiento
se arrepiente de algo
pues claro mentí a mis amigos
la actividad es de esperar que son las
actividades criminales en todos los
países
yo creo que lo más
sucio lo más sucio del día de que mía de
lo que hacía es las mentiras a la gente
que estimaba que aquí ya que es mis
amigos
estudio con con vladimir putin era un
buen espía él no no era bueno
el fracaso su carrera de espía
normalmente vino a moscú
para hacer un año de deformación en la
en esto tan drop voz en 1984 el mismo
año que queme el que yo después
normalmente debía quedarse en moscú en
en la sede de la primera dirección alta
dirección del café que fuera el servicio
del espacio exterior y fue enviado al en
grado día después fue enviado en la red
de app que era un país comunista
comunista
por amor es piano y su carrera en en el
café de usted continúa teniendo reflejos
de cuando era es pierre es decir
comprueba si le siguen pero hay muchos
casos en europa en europa occidental de
ex espías asesinados envenenados das
cristales está al 5 por ejemplo sí sí
después lideró los cadáveres el caso de
skripal tomó como algunas medidas de
seguridad pero claro no voy a decirlo
públicamente
caer en la mentira y caer en la paranoia
que espía actualmente rusia has hablado
mucho de esas injerencias rusas en las
elecciones estadounidenses en las
europeas que busca ahora rusia su
servicio secreto es no es claro no es
claro porque yo entonces putin no crea
ningún ninguna persona
la macro o bailén puede decirle a la
verdad
putin no lo que irá nunca es desconfiado
esa confianza completamente y por eso
tiene que tomar los documentos de la
oficina de los presidentes tenemos del
mundo entero
pero no es seriamente no no es
interesante porque ella actualmente en
los periódicos en las redacciones buenas
redacciones puede saber exactamente la
misma información creo que los
presidentes del mundo pero está espiando
y está interfiriendo en elecciones rusia
eso es diferente eso es diferente
en el gp no se le permitía el canje vivo
hacía las actividades secretas pero
nunca interfería en los procesos
democráticos del país extranjeros y
putin exactamente ssp ha dicho eso es
suyo ese es un cambio entonces sucede la
llegada de un cambio principal lo
principal y eso es el primer cambio el
segundo cambio es el ciber espionaje que
no existía en mi tiempo como convertiría
no teníamos ordenadores a ordenadores en
nuestra escuela justamente en el caso
del ciberespionaje a través del software
israelí pegasus rusia no ha aparecido
entre los países que compraron ese
software
esto no quiere decir que rusia nos pies
sino los declaraciones que tienen sus
propios programas y que software usa
rusia ya qué países se lo que es porque
la base
pero las malas lenguas dicen que el
software antiviral de kaspersky
sería un programa de drenaje de rusia
por ejemplo que alguien de los estados
unidos
a prohibido para los administración de
sal para las administraciones americanos
de utilidades por ese programa y hay
otros programas
sabemos que enuncia hay una fábrica de
troles aquí aquí y aquí van las redes
sociales etcétera pues hacen muchas
muchas cosas en el mundo aún necesitamos
espías en carne y hueso o no ahora ya se
trata sólo de softwares y finalmente tal
vez ya las empresas los gafas por
ejemplo sean más cosas que los servicios
secretos de los país los gafas a mi
juicio son más poderosos actualmente más
poderosos que los servicios las agencias
clásicas de los de los estados y no
tienen una cosa que las agencias no
tienen sé qué
es que nosotros mismos los damos los
datos
o peor o el mejor espía actualmente es
smartphone es el teléfono móvil que
tenemos sobre nosotros
quién es que nos sigue
a los espías finalmente los mejores
espías o peores somos nosotros mismos
muchísimas gracias señor
sergey shilov y muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes por habernos acompañado ya
saben que nos pueden seguir también por
internet en rf elmundo.com y en france24
punto com hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]